[Music]
I think we're all in agreement there's
going to change the world but
this revolution must not take place without leaving
the human factor out of all that
I'm not talking about the uprising of machines
I'm talking  no uprising of the
machines yet but should be pragmatic enough
concrete the problem is that the
ja are not able to reason on
the human context it poses
problems of bias it makes it
difficult to be able to take into
account in an ethical framework the ja
are hardly able to learn
from existing business expertise
, which means that they are
confined to large-scale
tasks or relatively simple tasks in
the end, AIs are
not really able to collaborate with
humans either  to learn and adapt to
their contact if you are stupid deploy them
in the four teeth in contexts
and in very very rigid processes and
what makes that the humans who are
in this  s contexts the suffer the
presence of his fellow colleagues
there and potentially feel
like robots it is not the best way
to create a collaborative
environment an environment of trust it is from
this observation the queue and in riedisheim
was created in  2010 is in Montreal and we
have set ourselves the ambition
of creating the conditions for a
synergy between humans and we are developing
an open source framework and common appeal
which allows doc to orchestrate
decision-making between agents there are
simulations and  humans this framework
there it is already used by a lot
of academics in the world of
machine learning look modeling for
example at the university of alberta by
matthew taylor at the thousand in montreal by
sarah chang d'art
this framework increased too  used in
the world of aeronautics, for example
thales, who use it to address the
challenges of man machine timming, therefore making
machines and humans work
together and  in this context we are going we have
the ambition to integrate the skaff program
it is one of the practices at the heart of
the skaff program and cogent has started to
deploy on two puppies skies we are talking
in particular at the moment
about network maintenance piloting sambre  of water
so to integrate us with confidence there
is first of all its features
aligned with our vision of ai and
the interaction between humans
and izia it is part of our
desire to  going beyond the
academic aeronautics market towards other markets and
is also part of our
upcoming installation of an r&d center in france
building trustworthy ai is
basically making bricks work together
which gives guarantees  of
performance guarantees of robustness
to explain compliance skills with
humans as beneficiaries but
also with humans as actors in
all of this and suddenly we re desire
trust and orchestrate decision-
making between all these  players there
decisions sequential and orchestrating an
intelligence ecosystem what we
call an intelligence ecosystem
that's what kaufman was
built for so we're really very
happy to join confident cia is to
enable all members of the
consortium to access
kobelt technology in order to create AIs that will
augment humans without replacing them
thank you thank you thank you so much
that america
[Music]